jetzt geht's auch ohne inhalte und zwar
um die truppen konzentration russischer
streitkräfte an der staatsgrenze der
ukraine
wir erleben wir eine truppen
konzentration an der grenze zur ukraine
durch russische truppen die ein maß
erreicht hat was wirklich
besorgniserregend ist und dass natürlich
insbesondere vor dem hintergrund dass
allgemein bekannt und anerkannt ist dass
russland schon bei denen jetzt noch
andauernden kampfhandlungen im osten der
ukraine aber natürlich auch bei der
annexion der krim mit durchaus auch
militärische unterstützung aber vielen
anderen hybriden mitteln die integrität
und souveränität der ukraine mehrfach
verletzt hat um meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren es ist ein kontinuum
deutsche außenpolitik und europäischer
außenpolitik dass die souveränität der
ukraine auch durch russland in keiner
weise infrage gestellt werden kann und
ich denke wir sollten gerade in dieser
zeit in einer übergangszeit auch
deutlich machen deutschland steht dazu
wir stehen an der seite der ukraine sie
muss souverän bleiben und jede
militärische intervention in der ukraine
muss von uns den müssen uns
entgegenstellen da müssen wir an der
seite der ukraine stehen und das müssen
wir ablehnen und russland dazu
auffordern insofern alle alles unberührt
zu lassen was die souveränität der
ukraine berührt in diesem sinne
war es glaube ich richtig dass
amerikanische präsident
mit dem russischen präsidenten ein
deutliches telefonats geführt hat und
auch die position des westens deutlich
gemacht hat und meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich möchte die bundesregierung an dieser
stelle aus fordern weil natürlich
präsident putin diesen augenblick auch
der konzentration von truppen nicht
zufällig gewählt hat er weiß dass es
einen regierungswechsel in deutschland
gibt er weiß dass es auch in frankreich
eine politisch etwas instabile situation
gibt weil in frankreich präsidentschafts
wahlen bevorstehen an dieser stelle die
allererste aufgabe der bundesrichter im
festlichen bündnis zu bleiben gemeinsam
mit der nato gemeinsam mit den unseren
partnerinnen und partnern in der
europäischen union ist sehr gut dass
außenministerin baerbock in diesen tagen
zuerst auch in paris wie es gute
deutsche tradition ist wir müssen mit
unseren westlichen partnern putin ein
signal der geschlossenheit geben nur das
zählt
und in diesem zusammenhang möchte ich
ausdrücklich begrüßen dass die
außenministerin schon in einem interview
den letzten tagen vor übernahme ihres
amtes auch klar worte der stärke
gebraucht habe aber meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wer den mund spitzt er
muss dann am ende auch pfeifen das heißt
wir werden auch darauf achten dass diese
neue koalition oder dass diese
bundesregierung ihre
bündnisverpflichtungen einhält denn es
wird darauf geachtet was deutschland
macht deutschland hat eine wesentliche
rolle im westlichen bündnis in der nato
in der europäischen union und es wird
darauf geachtet was deutschland macht
aber auch darauf geachtet was
deutschland gegebenenfalls nicht macht
und wenn wir zu sagen zwei prozent der
ausgaben des bruttosozialproduktes und
wir brauchen uns an der zahl nicht fest
sagt wir können auch sagen 10 der
fähigkeiten der nato beizutragen dann
muss deutschland diesen beitrag auch in
wirtschaftlich schwierigen zeiten
leisten alles andere zählt nur auf das
konto von putin ein und das gefährdet
die ukraine das gefährdet unsere
osteuropäischen bündnispartner und
deswegen muss deutschland hier
verlässlich sein dazu können wir sie nur
auffordern
dazu gehört auch das schwierige
beschaffungsvorhaben durchgeführt werden
müssen wir mit interesse gelesen dass
sie sich zur nuklearen teilhabe bekennen
dass sie das nachfolgesystem für den
tornado
befassen sollen wir aber eigentlich auch
gelesen das bauwerk etwas über
zertifizierungs fragen erörtert hat
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren an
der stelle muss auch klar sein so
schwierig das thema nukleare
abschreckung ist jeder der an der stelle
wackelt gefährdet die sicherheit des
westens und das darf deutschland nicht
riskieren deutschland muss hier klar
bleiben lieber herr kollege nouripour
ich bin ja mit ihnen der meinung politik
aus einem guss und nicht nur im
kanzleramt aber auch klarheit bei den
grünen und klar war in der grünen
außenministerin ist hier gefordert
vielen dank johann wadephul aus der
unionsfraktion einer der außenpolitiker
dort
den botschafter der ukraine in der muss
mit deutschland seine exzellenz dr andré
melnik
exzellent sein sonst kommt
also der botschafter der ukraine eben
deutschland ist auf der tribüne im
deutschen bundestag des deutschen
bundestages die gute frau dr die vögel
mit besonderer herzlichkeit
wir haben die vermieter angeglichen
nächster gegner ist danke schön herr
präsident hatte die verhöre gesagt die
werbeauftritte des bundestags der
letzten reihe da wo normalerweise die
vertreter der bundesländer sitzen
nächster redner ist nils schmid aus der
spd fraktion für
das angebot der guten zusammenarbeit in
der außenpolitik ich glaube wir sollten
in der tat die tradition einer bar eines
breiten konsenses in der außenpolitik
aufrechterhalten auch unter der neuen
regierungskonstellation und ich kann
sagen glaube im namen aller
koalitionsfraktionen dass wir daran
höchst interessiert sind und ich freue
mich auch dass die erste aktuelle
debatte die sieger aus fraktion
beantragt haben der außenpolitik
gewidmet ist
sehr verehrten damen und herren morgen
ist der fünfzigsten jahrestag der
verleihung des friedensnobelpreises an
willy brandt in seiner dankesrede prägte
er den satz
krieg ist nicht die ultima ratio
krieg ist die ultima ratio
und damit ist klar
friedenspolitik entspannungs politik
sind leitlinie deutscher außenpolitik
dieser bundesregierung
gerade auch mit blick auf die spannungen
zwischen russland und der ukraine und
dem russischen truppenaufmarsch an der
grenze der ukraine
und deshalb ist für uns als spd in
dieser situation eines glasklar
diplomatie ist das gebot der stunde
meine damen und herren
deshalb begrüßen wir das direkte
intensive gespräch zwischen dem
präsidenten beiden putin und deshalb
sind wir uns auch als deutschland der
besonderen verantwortung für das minsk
abkommen bewusst deutschland ist im
normandie format garantie start dieses
abkommens und wir wollen dieses abkommen
umsetzen es ist der einzig verfügbare
rahmen für eine nachhaltige
friedenslösung in der ost ukraine
es bedeutet aber auch dass russland sich
seiner verantwortung in diesem konflikt
bewusst sein muss es kann nicht sein
dass die russische regierung den kriegen
der ukraine als israelischen konflikt
abtut und sich quasi als eingebildeter
vermittler geriert nein russland ist
konfliktpartei russland ist aggressor
russland hat völkerrecht gebrochen und
massiv die europäische friedensordnung
gestört und deshalb ist für uns
entscheidend dass wir schnell wieder zu
einem normalen die treffen kommen mit
substanziellen fortschritten bei der
umsetzung des abkommens und zwar aller
teiles des abkommens aller betroffenen
parteien es ist für uns entscheidend
dass der nato-russland-rat
begleitend wiederbelebt wird dazu sollte
auch wussten sich wieder der
diplomatischen kontakte zur nato herrn
bemühen und es ist für uns entscheidend
dass das recht auf selbstbestimmung
aller staaten der ehemaligen sowjetunion
office ukraine belarus oder georgien ist
dass dieses respektiert wird diese
völker verdienen es selber demokratisch
darüber entscheiden zu können welchen
weg sie gehen wollen
in seiner regierungserklärung 1969 hat
willy brandt
neben der entspannungs politik das
kräftegleichgewicht das gleichgewicht
der kräfte als notwendige voraussetzung
für entspannen und dialog beschrieben
die erfolge der branchen außenpolitik
war nur möglich durch die westbindung
die nato mitgliedschaft und auch eine
modern ausgestattete bundeswehr das
waren zwei seiten einer medaille
und deshalb ist es richtig dass auch
heute die bundesrepublik deutschland die
bundesregierung sich klar zu diesen
grundsätzen bekennt und auch ausgehend
von diesen grundsätzen auf den ukrainer
russland konflikt schaut und deshalb bin
ich ganz stolz dankbar und der gesamten
bundesregierung dann war das von tag
eins an deutlich gemacht haben dass eine
russische aggression gegen die ukraine
konsequenzen haben wird und ich will
noch mal betonen für uns ist das klar
dass ausgehend von dem rahmen der
deutsch amerikanischen verständigung von
diesem sommer alle optionen auf dem
tisch liegen und das natürlich neue
sanktionen im falle einer solchen
aggression verhängt werden aber ich will
auch eins deutlich sagen wir sollten bis
zum letzten moment auch in dieser krise
darum kämpfen dass eine diplomatische
lösung gefunden wird kleine praktische
schritte sind jetzt notwendig meine
damen und herren vertrauensbildende
maßnahmen dass der waffenstillstand
wieder voll belebt wird dass die
übergänge an der konfliktlinie geöffnet
werden dass die osze-mission ihrem
auftrag ungehindert nachkommen kann dass
wir diese mission auch voll finanziell
und technisch unterstützen und dass wir
damit
den menschen in der ukraine eine
friedliche adventszeit bescheren können
das ist unser wunsch unser politisches
bestreben eine damen und herren hat sich
dann für ihre aufmerksamkeit sagte nils
schmid aus der spd fraktion in einer
aktuellen stunde die hier auf antrag der
unionsfraktion zustande gekommen ist zu
den truppen konzentrationen russischer
streitkräfte an der staatsgrenze der
ukraine und in eben dieser debatte wird
jetzt alexander gauland das wort
ergreifen aus der afg fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
zuerst möchte ich mal rügen dass die
außenministerin bei der ersten
außenpolitischen debatte nicht da ist
wir haben keine entschuldigung gehört
das
wo ist die ausbildung
dann muss man sich offiziell
entschuldigen
meine damen und herren kommen wir zum
thema ja es ist ungemütlich was da an
der grenze zwischen der ukraine und
russland passiert weniger weil man
einander stoßen befürchten muss als
vielmehr bei solche situation außer
kontrolle geraten können und es ist
deshalb gut und richtig wenn die
bundesregierung mit unseren verbündeten
ihre diplomatischen möglichkeiten nutzt
um die lage zu entspannen
weniger gut und richtig ist es die
schuld an dieser entwicklung immer nur
bei einer seite zu suchen
außenpolitik meine damen und herren und
diplomatie sollte vor den realitäten
ausgehen und realität ist nun einmal
dass russland die ordnung an seinen
grenzen als nicht befriedigend empfindet
ich will hier nicht den alten streit
wieder beleben ob es im rahmen der
wiedervereinigungs verhandlung eine
mündliche zusage gab die nato nicht über
die ehemalige ddr hinaus zu erweitern
wie es herr teltschik sagt an die
kollegen der cdu
das ist geschichte aber gegenwart ist
dass russland immer eine rote linie dort
gezogen hat wo es um alten russischen
siedlungsraum geht die ukraine und
weißrussland sind eben nicht mit polen
und ungarn zu vergleichen und eben auch
nicht mit denen im rahmen des hitler
stalin paktes annektierten baltischen
staaten wir haben es insoweit eben noch
nicht mit einer allseits akzeptierten
friedensordnung zu tun trotz des
vertrages von 1994
wir haben alle daran hatte ich kenne das
gegenargument des westens ist gebe keine
einflusssphären mehr und auch diese
länder seien frei ihre bündnisse zu
wählen dieses argument mag
völkerrechtlich richtig sein politisch
trägt es nicht meine damen und herren
denn auch die amerikaner haben 1961 in
der kuba krise
völlig zu recht darauf bestanden dass
mittelstreckenraketen in ihrem hinterhof
für den weltfrieden nicht akzeptabel
seien auch kubas souveränität musste
damals hinter einer einflusssphäre einer
großmacht zurückstehen liebe freunde das
sollten sich vor allem die kollegen der
cdu hinter die ohren schreiben
übrigens genau wie auf der anderen seite
finnland dessen neutralität auch nicht
eine ganz freiwillige war und ist
es gibt nun einmal historisch politische
gegebenheiten die die handlungsfreiheit
eines staates auch ohne rechtliche
verpflichtung einschränken deshalb ist
es nicht klug auf etwas zu bestehen was
von russland als eine nicht
hinzunehmende provokation betrachtet
wird die immer stärkere verflechtung der
ukraine aber auch georgiens mit
westlichen sicherheitsstrukturen
auch wenn es den regelbasierten
multilateral ist schwer fällt der
sicherheit und unabhängigkeit der
ukraine ist mit einer auch von russland
akzeptierten neutralität besser gedient
als mit waffenlieferung oder einer
nato-mitgliedschaft meine damen und
herren
solange russland
die phantomschmerzen eines zerbrochenen
reiches mit sich herumschleppt sollte
der westen dies bei seinen reaktionen
berücksichtigen und jede weitere
ausdehnung seiner ordnung gegen die
russischen grenze entsagen
denn nicht meine damen und herren zuerst
das völkerrecht sondern vor allem die
politische klugheit
sichert das friedliche zusammenleben von
völkern und staaten und meine damen und
herren gerade wir deutschen hätten die
aufgabe dies auch der ukraine deutlich
zu machen ich bedanke mich
vielen dank herr kollege dr
liebe kollegen die eingetreten bevor ist
die autobahn ganz klar benennt die
einladenden eco hin dass kollegen
veranlassen mich zu einer feststellung
die außenminister sowie deutschland in
der burg hat sich ordnungsgemäß beim
bundestag in wahrnehmung gibt es die
aufgaben abgemeldet was auch
selbstverständlich ist und ich will
darauf hinweisen
man hätte dass das in paris sich aufhält
nach brüssel weiter fließt und morgen
warschauer sein wird schon seit gestern
abend die presse entwicklung nehmen
können
man muss im digitalen zeitalter nicht
auch gedrucktes papier warten bis man
diese erkenntnis gewinnen als nächster
reden hat der kollege jürgen trittin das
wort
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
helgoland als ich eben das wort gehört
habe von dem alten russischen
siedlungsraum
habe ich an meine jugend gedacht
da hat es auch solche äußerungen aus
deutschland gegeben was alles zu
deutschland gehören würde dreigeteilt
niemals von der etsch bis an den belt
und also etwas und ich sage ihnen eins
die basis der gemeinsamen
ordnung der friedensordnung in europa
ist dass niemand sich mehr auf solchen
unsinn berufen kann die straße ist die
und taster kite der grenze und das
verbot grenzen einseitig gewaltsam zu
ändern und im riesen gemeinsamen europa
sind sie offensichtlich noch nicht
angekommen ich will einen weiteren punkt
hinzufügen sollte er dieser tage viel
von celtic von hans dietrich genscher ja
es gibt diese äußerung aber
ich will mal eins deutlich sagen es ist
nicht die nato die 120 tausend soldaten
und soldaten an der grenze eines
souveränen staates in
gefechtsbereitschaft
konzentriert hat und egal ob das der
vorbereitung einer invasion oder der
bloßen erpressung der ukraine dient
dieses ist mit dem regeln mit dem geist
des vertrages über sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa nicht vereinbar
und da ist auch russland
vertragsbestandteil
herr schmidt in der seite wo sie haben
ja zu recht darauf verwiesen dass es gut
ist in dieser situation dass präsident
biden präsident putin miteinander
sprechen aber
das ist auch für uns ein problem
denn was macht den krater
er nutzt die die stabilisierung in
europa
um auf großer bühne zu simulieren er
wäre auf einer in einer liga mit der
großmacht der usa
und ich finde da beginnt für uns die
außenpolitische herausforderung nicht
nur als deutsche sondern als europäer
wir können uns in dieser form nicht da
zum spielball machen lassen
singh ist es unsere verantwortung dieses
stück
selbstbewusstsein zu haben das für die
sicherheit in europa auch wir unseren
teil zu tragen haben und dabei gilt der
alte grundsatz
von egon bahr
amerika ist unverzichtbar und russland
ist unverrückbar und
deswegen glaube ich dass es wichtig ist
dass wir das normandie format wieder
instand setzen dass es eine klare und
schnelle initiative gibt die die ursache
des konfliktes die putin zum anlass
nimmt um sein spiel mit den usa zu
spielen endlich aus der welt schaffen
und dazu bedarf es der
verlässlichkeit
die verlässlichkeit heißt europa wird
seine politische und seine
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit mit der
ukraine nicht nur nicht einstellen
sondern wir wollen sie ausbauen wir
wollen mit der ukraine zusammen arbeiten
beim um in einer wasserstoffwirtschaft
wir wollen dieses politische system wir
wollen auch freiheit für die menschen
die hier an dieser stelle haben
eine stabile und prosperierende ukraine
ist im europäischen interesse an dieser
debatte dazu gehört auch ehrlichkeit es
stimmt es gibt keine militärische lösung
dieses konflikts ich sage auch deutlich
gute beziehungen zur ukraine richten
sich gegen niemanden auch nicht gegen
russland sicherheit in europa wird das
nicht gegen russland
aber wir wollen sicherheit in europa mit
russland deswegen ist der
nato-russland-rat wichtig
aber
dies geschieht auf einer kritischen
grundlage
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit kann es
nur auf der basis der vertraglich
vereinbarten friedensordnung dieses
kontinents geben und wird diese
friedensordnung
militärisch in frage stellt der darf
nicht glauben dass anschließend business
as usual einfach so weitergeht der hört
die gesamten beziehungen zwischen
russland militär die ganzen beziehung
zwischen russland und der europäischen
union politisch und wirtschaftlich in
frage stellen das kann nicht im
interesse russlands sein denn wenn putin
so weiter macht und diese beziehung in
frage stellt dann wird da nicht in einer
liga mit den usa spielen sondern als was
chinas enden und deswegen sie haben nach
der haltung der bundesregierung gefragt
zu dem konflikt ich kann ihnen sagen die
wichtigste haltung ist europa in dieser
frage zusammen zu halten und deswegen
ist es gut dass die deutsche
aussenminister und heute in paris in
brüssel und in warschau
jürgen trittin außenpolitiker der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen sagt die
verlässlichkeit europas sei für die
ukraine wichtig und wird seine
parteifreundin berbalk als neue
außenministerin
dazu sicher ihren beitrag auf eu-ebene
leisten müssen und wir haben hier eine
premiere als redner im bundestag nämlich
ali al dailami aus der fraktion die
linke
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren mit großer
sorge beobachten auch wir als linke
derzeit die entwicklung an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze und dem
sport weiter zuspitzenden konflikt um es
klar zu sagen als linke lehnen wir
jegliche militärische drohgebärden ab
egal von welcher seite und wir sagen
auch klar krieg darf niemals das mittel
der politik sein
ja der militärische aufmarsch und die
konzentration der russischen truppen
sind gefährlich aber auch aktionen auf
der gegenseite sind nicht weniger
problematisch
die aufrüstung der ukraine durch die usa
die türkei und weitere nato staaten
sowie auch die stationierung von nato
militärausbildern in der ukraine sorgen
für erheblichen zündstoff in diesem
konflikt und dieser region
militärmanöver und eine massive hoch
rüstungspolitik haben sich bisher immer
als kontraproduktiv erwiesen mehr noch
sie haben ja regelrecht zu dieser
exklusiven lage zumindest mit
beigetragen und das muss sofort
eingestellt werden notwendig sind
stattdessen vereinbarungen zur
rüstungskontrolle aber auch zur
gemeinsamen abrüstung
genauso kontraproduktiv die die
aufrüstung ist es zu glauben dass man
diesen konflikt mit einer spirale von
sanktionen eindämmen oder gar befrieden
kann ich sage ihnen das gegenteil ist
der fall das hat die vergangenheit
eindrücklich bewiesen und auch deshalb
lehnen wir diese fatale sanktionspolitik
als linke konsequent ab
vielmehr muss es jetzt darum gehen die
verhandlungen wieder aufzunehmen und
dazu gehört eben das anknüpfen an die
minsker abkommen deutschland und
frankreich die an diesen vereinbarungen
schon beteiligt waren kommt hier eben
eine besondere aufgabe auch
verantwortung zu was wir also jetzt
brauchen ist kein säbelrasseln sondern
eine klug durchdachte also
deeskalierende und auf den dialog setzen
die politik
dazu gehört eben keine einseitige
parteinahme sondern vor allem das
anerkennen der interessen und sorgen der
beteiligten akteure
und ja es geht auch um die territoriale
integrität der ukraine aber natürlich
auch die sorge russlands dass die nato
nachweisbar immer weiter in richtung des
eigenen staatsgebietes verrückt und hier
will ich sehr deutlich sagen die
ehemalige bundeskanzlerin hat so einiges
falsch gemacht aber sie lernt
goldrichtig damit dass die sich all
jenen widersetzt hat die gefordert haben
der ukraine waffen zu liefern mit denen
dann womöglich versucht worden wäre
diesen konflikt weiter zu eskalieren und
die neue bundesregierung wäre gut
beraten diesen 40 zu erneuern
insbesondere dann wenn jetzige
regierungsmitglieder genau dies
forderten ist sage ihnen ist kann und
darf doch nicht das ziel deutscher
außenpolitik sein mit waffenlieferungen
in krisengebiete immer weiter öl ins
feuer zu gießen meine damen kennen
und zur historischen verantwortung
deutschlands gehört ist dafür sorge zu
tragen dass alles dafür getan werden
muss damit es in europa nicht zu einem
neuen großen krieg kommt zur
historischen verantwortung gehört es
aber auch sich fragen zu lassen wie es
denn wahr genommen wird will die neue
bundes bundesregierung sich anschickt
weiter aufzurüsten und so auf dem weg
ist zur ausgaben ausgaben stärksten
militärmacht in europa zu werden auch
aus diesem grunde lehnen wir diese
aufrüstungspolitik stichwort bewaffnete
drohnen rigoros ab
meine damen und herren noch ist es zeit
den seit jahren andauernden konflikt
zumindest soweit zu befrieden dass wir
wieder zum dialog und somit einer
politik der entspannung kommen denn wenn
eine entspannungs politik im vor
ideologisierten kalten krieg möglich war
dann ist sie ist heute allemal alles
andere wäre verantwortungslos und eine
bankrotterklärung und
ein letzter satz zu allerletzt als
deutsche bundesregierung können und
sollten sie aus eben genannten gründen
eine vermittlerrolle einnehmen
verspielen sie das nicht durch eine
einseitige parteinahme
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
ali al dailami war das für die
linksfraktion es war seine erste rede im
deutschen bundestag
ja ist ja auch natürlich ist das erste
mal im parlament und sie sehen auch die
präsidentschaft hat gewechselt
jetzt führt aydan özoguz durch diese
bundestagssitzung und damit im moment
auch durch diese aktuelle stunde in der
jetzt alexander graf lambsdorff für die
fdp spricht ganz herzlichen dank ich
möchte beginnen hier auch mit einem dank
an die kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union die hier in der ersten grossen
aussenpolitischen debatte in der neuen
legislaturperiode die hand gereicht
haben zur zusammenarbeit zu kontinuität
ich finde das aller ehren wert und wir
werden darauf eingehen bei jeder
gelegenheit die sich bietet die bombarde
polen ich möchte
in dem zusammenhang allerdings lieber
jahren einen kritikpunkt den du hier
vorgetragen hast gleich wieder legen
und zwar hast du ja in frage gestellt ob
es denn dieser koalition gelingen werde
kontinuität weil so absolut zentralen
bündnis politischen fragen wie
beispielsweise der nuklearen teilhabe zu
bewahren und mit erlaubnis der
präsidentin zitiere ich mal aus dem
koalitionsvertrag
thema nukleare teilhabe so lange
kernwaffen im strategischen konzept der
nato eine rolle spielen hat deutschland
ein interesse daran an den strategischen
diskussionen und planungsprozessen
teilzuhaben
das meine damen und herren bei der
koalitionsvertrag 2013 ich zitiere aus
dem koalitionsvertrag 2018 solange
kernwaffen im strategischen konzept der
nato eine rolle spielen hat deutschland
ein interesse daran an den strategischen
diskussionen und planungsprozessen
teilzuhaben und mit erlaubnis der
präsidentin zitiere ich jetzt aus dem
koalitionsvertrag dieses jahres von 2021
solange kernwaffen im strategischen
konzept der nato eine rolle spielen hat
deutschland ein interesse daran an den
strategischen diskussionen und
planungsprozessen teilzuhaben meine
damen und herren mehr kontinuität in
einer so wichtigen bündnispolitischen
frage kann es kaum geben und ich muss
ihnen sagen das ist genau das worauf wir
setzen in den kernpunkten der
bundesrepublikanischen der deutschen
außenpolitik wird es kontinuität geben
aber meine damen und herren es wird auch
wandel geben es wird wandel auch in der
außenpolitik geben genau deswegen weil
sich natürlich auch die außenpolitik
andere akteure wandelt nehmen wir nur
mal bitte die russische außenpolitik
dieses jahres im april das große manöver
saab hat viel größer als sonst im osten
norden im süden der ukraine große
truppenstationierungen kursk woronesch
castorf im juni dann der gipfel putin
beiden gott sei dank wir dachten mensch
vielleicht wird's ein bisschen
kooperativer was passiert im september
tauchen wagner söldner in mali auf wo
die bundeswehr stationiert ist im
oktober erklärt die russische föderation
den abbruch der beziehungen zur nato im
november helga die mir putin reden auf
der waldau konferenz- und bei seinem
land botschaftern er suche zwar kein
konflikt an der westgrenze aber
gleichzeitig sehen wir november und
dezember einen enormen einen enormen
truppen aufwuchs eine enorme truppen
konzentration erneut an der staatsgrenze
zur ukraine und meine damen und herren
auf solche situationen müssen wir
eingehen
es gibt in der russischen außenpolitik
diesen satz wer nicht auf lavrov hören
will der bekommt es mit streugut zu tun
also wenig wie auf den außenminister
hört bekommt es mit dem
verteidigungsminister zu tun das ist
aber nicht als eine nachgelagerte
nacheinander zu verstehende sache zu
verstehen das geschieht ja die ganze
zeit gleichzeitig die russische
föderation und das ist nicht unser
wunsch aber seine realität mit der wir
umzugehen haben setzt das militär als
außenpolitisches instrument ein und
genau das ist hier auch wieder der
parlamente damen und herren das ist
nicht unser wunsch so zu operieren aber
das bedeutet eines ganz klar und da sind
wir wieder beim thema kontinuität
kollege nils schmid hat es wie ich finde
hervorragend gesagt unsere gesamte
politik gegenüber der russischen
föderation müssen wir im bündnis machen
in der festen verankerung des westens
von dort aus unterstützen wir die
ukraine von dort aus versuchen wir
entspannung zu erreichen und deswegen
ist es so wichtig dass der
koalitionsvertrag auch beim thema nato
so klar ist und das ist mir auch wichtig
willy brandts zitiert worden als wir die
brandt bundeskanzler war gab die
bundesrepublik 3,7 prozent ihrer
wirtschaftsleistung für die bundeswehr
aus 3,7 prozent da wären wir nicht
hinkommen wollen aber lieber johann
wadephul
im koalitionsvertrag steht klar drin wir
wollen drei prozent für unsere
internationale politik ausgeben auch um
den in der nato eingegangenen
verpflichtungen nachkommen zu können
also ich glaube dass auch hier unsere
bündnis politische treue vollkommen klar
ist bei den drei prozent ist aber auch
die entwicklungszusammenarbeit dabei den
0,7 prozent oder quote ist eine stärkung
unserer diplomatie dabei und diplomatie
ist ja genau das womit wir jetzt gerade
versuchen die lage zu entspannen die
russisch-amerikanischen konsultationen
begrüße ich aber was ich bin das begrüße
ist dass die amerikanische seite vor den
gesprächen mit russland die nato
verbündeten auch die bundesrepublik
deutschland so intensiv konsultiert hat
das mit der ukraine gesprochen worden
ist das ist heute ein gespräch gibt der
bukarest 9 mit den usa man könnte
glauben man hat einen weißen haus
unserem koalitionsvertrag gelesen denn
wir wollen die russlandpolitik unter
besonderer berücksichtigung auch der
interessen unserer mittel und
osteuropäischen partner gestalten das
finden wir gut und genau das ist unser
ziel mit diplomatie zur deeskalation
beizutragen für die unterstützung der
ukraine für frieden in europa herzlichen
dank meine damen und herren
so viel zeit muss sein vielen dank herr
kollege
und ich darf das wort nunmehr teilen
christian petry von der spd fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen
der europäische aspekt ist auch in
dieser debatte ein wesentlicher aspekt
herr kollege wadephul hat es genannt die
euro die ukraine muss ein souveräner
staat bleiben ich sehe zwar nicht die
akute gefahr dass das sich akut ändert
aber dass das ein grundsatz europäischer
politik sein muss ich glaube das sind
die demokraten hier in diesem hause
einer meinung das ist ein zentraler
punkt den wir auch in der europa politik
immer wieder betonen müssen liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
120.000 soldaten
an der grenze können da nicht über nacht
hinkommen die können auch nicht einfach
so hin fahren und dort übernachten dort
muss es also eine entsprechende
vorbereitung geben eine entsprechende
logistik geben das wird auch nicht über
nacht gehen ich glaube dass es schon
bemerkenswert
und wir müssen natürlich genau
hinschauen wie diese bedrohungslage sich
auswirkt meine gespräche die ich mit
kolleginnen kollegen in der ukraine kiew
geführt haben ist erstaunlicherweise in
kiew selbst wird diese bedrohung nicht
so hoch gesehen wie wir dies vermuten
müssen aber dennoch wird dort letztlich
gesehen welches gefährdungspotenzial
darin steht ob damit fakten im dom bass
geschaffen werden russische pässe rubel
jetzt auch russisches militär
ähnlich wie in aktien oder südossetien
in georgien ist dass das ziel dieser
intervention die kommen könnte auch das
wäre etwas was wir mit aller
die
zurückweisen müssen und die europäische
gemeinschaft muss hier auch solidarisch
zusammenstehen und ein gemeinsames
signal setzen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wie sagt man so schön ein bock stößt
selten allein
türkische drohnen im einsatz bei der
ukraine
amerikanischen abwehrraketen im einsatz
bei der ukraine sind auch verstöße gegen
das minsker abkommen und sind auch dinge
wo wir in einem und ich bin sehr dafür
nach der mehrfachen forderung nils
schmid hans genannt die diplomatie das
normandie format muss aufrecht muss
reaktiviert werden dass wir dort dies
sehr klar zum ausdruck bringen dass auch
diese dinge wechselseitige provokationen
oder darüber hinausgehend nicht gehen
und dies auch von europäischer seite
entsprechend benannt werden muss denn
eine einseitige vorgehensweise halte ich
selbstverständlich auch für falsch weil
sie liebe kolleginnen kollegen sicher
nicht zielführend sein wird darauf
müssen wir achten
vielen dank von der linken seite das
freut mich sehr
ja wo geht die reise hin wir haben es
heute schon mehrfach gehört in russland
unter putin der weg von der demokratie
zur autokratie
dagegen aber das unverrückbare die
unverrückbare wahrheit dass wir in
europa europäische politik nur mit
russland machen können dauerhaft stabil
auch nur mit russland machen können wir
wollen aber nicht die situation
dauerhaft hinnehmen wie sie jetzt in der
ukraine sich abzeichnen wie sie in
georgien schon im alltag sind wie in
moldawien eingefroren auch potenziale
stecken in belarus noch gar nicht zu
sprechen das sind dinge wo wir
tatsächlich aufpassen müssen und wo wir
das ist mein appell von dieser stelle
eine stärkung der europäischen politik
auch brauchen neben dem normalen die
format ist es ab mut notwendig wenn wir
eine europäische souveränität wollen
eingebettet in eine nato strategie dann
müssen wir auch hier europäisch mit
unseren partnern mit frankreich mit
allen anderen handeln können dass es
nicht einfach bei den unterschiedlichen
ausgangslagen aber unabdingbar denn wenn
wir zum fünfzigsten jahrestag des der
friedensnobelpreis verleihung an willy
brandt es ernst nehmen mit den zielen
der entspannung und irgendwann auch
wirklich mal wieder zu einer abrüstungs
debatte kommen und nicht permanent zu
einer aufrüstung debatte und sie
unterhalten müssen dann müssen wir sagen
wir brauchen wir die europäische
souveränität wir brauchen ein klares
signal keine erpressung keine aggression
keine wechselseitigen provokationen wir
brauchen die und jürgen trittin als
genannt stabile friedensordnung in
europa die von allen eingehalten werden
müssen und dazu gehört
selbstverständlich die ukraine und aus
russland und wir müssen unseren beitrag
dazu leisten in einer gestärkten
vorgehensweise der europäischen union
das ist die forderung nächste woche am
13 tag der auswärtige ausschuss
der europäer auswärtige rat für
auswärtige angelegenheiten der eu da
können die außenminister ebenfalls
bereits ein signal der geschlossenheit
setzen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit für auf christian petry
aus der spd fraktion in einer aktuellen
stunde die auf antrag der
unionsfraktionen zustande gekommen ist
über tropen konzentration russischer
streitkräfte an der staatsgrenze der
ukraine und in dieser debatte erklärt
jürgen hardt zu wort kommen in der
letzten legislatur außenpolitischer
sprecher der unionsfraktion
da arbeiten die fraktion ja noch an den
sprecherinnen und sprechern aber auch
das wird sich im laufe der nächsten tage
lichten
debatte möchte ich doch die gelegenheit
nutzen auf den ein oder anderen aspekt
einzugehen der bereits angesprochen
wurde ohne alles wichtige was gesagt
wurde von vielen fraktionen zu
wiederholen
johann david wadephul
hat sich zum koalitionsvertrag und den
aussenpolitischen aspekten geäußert
jawohl wir haben uns ein wenig die augen
gerieben was in diesem koalitionsvertrag
möglicherweise möglich sein könnte von
den dingen die uns in den letzten vier
jahren in der großen koalition beschwert
haben es war uns nicht möglich eine
entscheidung zu treffen zur
anschluss beschaffung für die flugzeuge
wir brauchen für die nukleare teilhabe
es war uns nicht möglich bewaffnete
drohnen an zu schaffen weil die spd uns
das leider nicht mitgemacht hat wir sind
gespannt darauf wie ist der neuen
position gelingt das hinzukriegen ich
freue mich drauf lieber auch mit mopo
wenn du als vielleicht parteivorsitzende
der grünen dann auf deine parteitag
durchsetzt dass amerikanische
kampfflugzeuge für die nukleare teilhabe
angeschafft werden oder bewaffnete
drohnen für die bundeswehr wenn du das
hinkriegt dann wenn du das wenn du das
hinkriegt dann wirst du beim respekt
haben aber bis dahin bei uns die skepsis
doch bitteschön erlaubt
schöne an dieser debatte ist dass wir
uns in der mitte des hauses völlig einig
sind in der bewertung dessen was hat das
hauptthema unserer aktuellen stunde ist
nämlich dass wir die art und weise wie
russland massiven druck auf die ukraine
ausübt aufs schärfste verurteilen ich
finde es total zynisch was der
außenpolitische berater des russischen
präsidenten der usa kopf
im anschluss an das telefonat der beiden
präsidenten usa russland gesagt hat er
wisse gar nicht worum es gehe wo
russland die soldaten hin verlegen
sollte sie würden sich ja vor sich mit
staatsgebiet aufhalten also erster
vorschlag diese truppen könnten dahin
zurück verlegt werden wo sie her sind
nämlich hinter moral großer teil dieser
streitkräfte sind sonst in sibirien ist
stationiert und zweitens sollen wir den
aus dieser aussage den schluss ziehen
dass unsere zusage unsere einseitige
zusage der nato gegenüber russland das
wäre keine substanziellen streitkräfte
östlich des bisherigen des früheren nato
gebiets stationieren eben um einfach zu
zeigen dass wir friedliche absicht haben
und nicht militärisch drohen sollen wir
diese zusage etwa einpacken weil sie
offensichtlich aus russischer sicht
keine rolle spielt das kann ja wohl
nicht der ernst sein diese könig weiss
ich aufs schärfste zurück und ich glaube
das ist ein stück entlarvend für die
haltung der russischen regierung
blick auf die situation im konflikt
russland ukraine ist die
völkerrechtliche bewertung sonnenklar
und wehen nun sagt völkerrecht könnte
man durch politische klugheit
relativieren der bewegt sich auf dem
trottoir der des neunzehnten und
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts und ich sage an
die adresse der afg ist das wirklich im
sinne deutschlands
wenn wir der meinung sind das
völkerrecht relativiert köln sein könnte
durch politische realitäten das würde ja
für ein land wie deutschland das fried
liebt ist und vielleicht nicht so groß
wie andere länder auf dieser erde
bedeuten dass wir uns dem druck etwa
chinas russlands oder auch von mir aus
anderer großer staaten beugen müssen im
gegenteil gerade ist es im sinne des
deutschlands und im sinne deutschen
patriotismus dass man sagt völkerrecht
hat unbedingten vorrang vor allen
anderen vor allen anderen dingen und das
finde ich sollte man deutlich sagt
im ukraine konflikt müssen wir nüchtern
feststellen dass sowohl als russischer
als auch aus westlicher sicht lästig und
ukrainischer sicht ja vieles von dem was
wir
einseitig erwartet und befürchtet hatten
2014 nach dem einmarsch russlands auf
der krim und der einmischung in der ost
ukraine so nicht eingetreten sind auch
aus russland sicht
geht ja die rechnung nicht auf dass
durch diese aktion sich die ukraine ein
stück weit von europa von europäischen
union in fremden würde im gegenteil ich
glaube dass die haltung innerhalb der
ukraine pro europäische union eher noch
zugenommen hat durch diese aggression
russlands und ich glaube auch dass putin
nüchtern feststellen muss dass diese
aktion hier im frühjahr im januar 2014
begonnen hat dass diese aktion sehr viel
geld und sehr viel ressourcen bindet
nicht nur militärisch sondern auch
ökonomisch und dass das ein abenteuer
war das letztlich doch in eine sackgasse
situation geführt hat unsererseits und
das sage ich in anwesenheit des werten
herrn botschafters ist natürlich die
erwartung dass die ukrainische regierung
ein alles tut dafür dass dieses land ein
starkes prosperierendes land wird das
auch als vorbild für alle diejenigen
dient die meinen man könnte unter
russischer verschafft gleich besser
leben als in einer freien demokratischen
pluralistischen frei marktwirtschaftlich
organisierten gesellschaft deswegen mein
appell an die
ukrainische regierung lassen sie uns
gemeinsam den weg weiter voranschreiten
damit die ukraine auch zu einem
leuchtenden positiven beispiel für die
ganze region für ganz mittelosteuropa
wird das hilft uns ganz entscheidend bei
beim zurückdrängen dieser russischen
aggression dankeschön
jürgen hardt ist schon ein klein wenig
länger im deutschen bundestag ihm folgte
wieder ein neuling im parlament und
erhält jetzt auch gleich seine erste
rede hier im deutschen bundestag das ist
robin wagener aus der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen er war richter bevor er
ins parlament einzog und er kommt aus
ostwestfalen
[Gelächter]
der geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit dieser
aktuellen stunde heute debattieren wir
eine der größten friedenspolitischen
herausforderungen unserer zeit die
wiederholten militärischen drohgebärden
und eskalationen des kremls gegen die
ukraine
gestern haben wir hier das hohe fest der
demokratie in diesem haus gefeiert die
friedliche der friedliche wechsel die
friedliche übertragung von macht wir
feiern die funktionierende demokratie
und den rechtsstaat als mitglied in
einer union der freiheit der sicherheit
und des rechts
eine europäischen union
[Applaus]
keine europäischen union die leitstellen
vieler menschen ist und bleibt zum
beispiel der menschen in der ukraine
diese vision von demokratie von freiheit
sicherheit und recht hat die vielen
tausend menschen in der ukraine vor acht
jahren bewegt und auch den euro weiter
angebracht
sie forderten diese werte ein sie
forderten demokratie gerechtigkeit
freiheit
rechtsstaatlichkeit menschenwürde und
die annäherung an die europäische union
die annäherung und einen weg der
grundsätzlich jedem europäischen staat
offen steht der sich zu den werten der
eu bekennt und sie fördert ein weg auf
dem es für jeden der ihn beschreitet
herausforderungen und hürden gibt aber
keine roten linien von außen
die menschen in der ukraine forderten
das recht auf eine souveräne
entscheidung über die zukunft ihres
landes
es war und bleibt dieser unbedingte
wille auf einen eigenständigen
demokratisch legitimierten weg den die
regierung in russland nicht begreifen
kann und nicht anerkennen will
auch acht jahre nach den eurofightern
nach bedeutsamen reform und
erfolgreichen demokratischen wahlen in
der ukraine leugnet das russische
staatsoberhaupt weiter die souveränität
der ukraine ignoriert deren verfassung
und degradiert unseren partner zu einem
vermeintlichen künstlichen konstrukt
es sind derlei aussagen in verbindung
mit den wiederkehrenden militärischen
bedrohung sei es im asowschen meer oder
mit den truppen aufmärschen an der
grenze jetzt gerade die schmerzhaft
deutlich zeigen dass sich präsident
putin in offene ablehnung zu den werten
positioniert die wir gemeinsam in europa
vereinbart haben
meine damen und herren mit der charta
von paris haben wir 1990 eine gemeinsame
europäische friedensordnung geschaffen
eine ordnung in der die stärke des
rechts gilt und nicht das vorrecht ist
vermeintlich stärkeren
eine friedensordnung in der konflikt am
verhandlungstisch und nicht auf
schlachtfeldern gelöst werden präsident
putins militärische drohgebärden an der
grenze zur ukraine richten sich gegen
die gesamte europäische friedensordnung
seit 2004 10 erleben wir einen krieg im
don was mit weit über 13.000 todesopfern
auf der ukrainischen seite allein in
diesem jahr sind bereits über 76
ukrainische soldaten trotz eines
vereinbarten waffenstillstands getötet
worden
auch auf russischer seite führt die
aggression des kremls zu weiteren opfern
und dabei ist für uns alle doch eins
klar jedes einzelne kriegsopfer ist ein
verlorenes menschen leben zu füllen
auf der besetzten krim sehen wir die
konsequenzen konsequenzen russischer
herrschaft unabhängige medien werden
unterdrückt menschenrechte verletzt und
von der kontakt linie im don was
erreichen uns berichte wonach russische
scharfschützen an der kontakt linie
ausgebildet werden und dabei makabere
signaturen auf ihren opfer hinterlassen
diese bittere ukrainische realität wird
viel zu selten debattiert wenn wir uns
mit den phantomschmerzen des kremls
beschäftigen
mit blick auf putins jüngste eskalation
ist 1 glasklar wir können und werden als
europäerinnen und europäer eine politik
der vorgehaltenen waffe und schon gar
nicht den einsatz von waffengewalt
teilnahmslos hinnehmen
sollte es sollte es zu einer weiteren
verletzung der territorialen integrität
der ukraine kommen dann steht fest dass
dies erhebliche wirtschaftliche und
politische konsequenzen hätte
aber wir sind als politikerinnen und
politiker gewählt um all unsere kraft
darauf zu lenken solche eskalationen zu
verhindern wir sind gewählt um die macht
des wortes zu nutzen und dem dialog die
spannungen abzubauen aber nicht in einem
dialog zum schönen schein sondern ernst
gemeint und mit substanziellen
gesprächen über die wiederherstellung
der vollen territorialen integrität und
der souveränität der ukraine so wie wir
es im koalitionsvertrag festgeschrieben
haben
und damit ist auch klar dass unser weg
nach moskau in diesen fragen stets über
kia führen wird im dialog mit der
russischen regierung für den frieden und
die freiheit gemeinsam mit unseren
europäischen und amerikanischen
partnerinnen und partnern und immer
unter anerkennung der vollen
souveränität derjenigen um die es geht
der menschen in der ukraine vielen dank
robin wagner aus der fraktion bündnis
90/die grüne mit seiner jungfernrede
hier im deutschen bundestag und damit
sind wir schon beim drittletzten redner
angekommen in dieser aktuellen stunde
zur drogen konzentration russischer
streitkräfte an der staatsgrenze der
ukraine und es spricht michael georg
link fdp fraktion in der letzten
legislaturperiode
europapolitischer sprecher und wenn er
bleibt wird der ausschussvorsitzende mit
dem er in dieser legislaturperiode zu
tun hat ein tor hat hofreiter seien die
kollegen der unionsfraktion dass wir
heute wirklich die erste aktuelle stunde
zur außenpolitik machen denn
bundesregierung aber auch vor allem
dieses parlament der bundestag stellen
sich sofort der internationalen
verantwortung und es ist wichtig dass
wir hier gemeinsam akzente so weit wie
möglich setzen das haben wir übrigens
auch uns beim koalitionsvertrag auch zu
grunde genommen wir haben gewusst dass
wir nicht in einem luftleeren raum
verhandeln sondern in einer situation wo
wir gestiegenen bedrohungen als
europäische union und auch als
deutschland ausgesetzt sind das finden
sie wieder das finden sie wieder in
unseren formulierung die wir zum
beispiel zum thema china gewählt haben
die wir zum thema russland gewählt haben
wir stellen uns diesen bedrohungen und
wir wissen dass wir da auch mehr machen
müssen und mehr gemeinsam machen wollen
liebe kolleginnen kollegen ist es viel
richtig ist ein wichtiges gesagt worden
über die gesamte situation in der wir
uns befinden lassen sie mich etwas über
die motivation vielleicht nochmal
hinzufügen die insbesondere von seiten
so wie wir es verstehen von der
russischen führung kommt und wenn wir
hier kritik an russland äußern lassen
sie mich eines deutlich sagen es ist
niemals kritik am russischen volk ist
niemals kritik an der russischen kultur
sprache oder an dem engen verhältnis mit
russland worden es ist eine klare kritik
an der russischen führung die diese
stadt die es diesen staat und dieses
großartige volk in einer geopolitischen
zwangs jahr gehalten mit einem denken
des 19 jahrhunderts des nullsummenspiel
was der heutigen welt nicht angemessen
ist
was wir viel mehr feststellen ist einen
simultanen prozess einen simultanen
prozess schon seit mehreren jahren der
steigenden des steigenden drucks im
politisch in russland und des steigenden
drucks auf nachbarn das ist ein prozess
der manchmal eine zeit wo begeht und wir
ihnen das mal nicht so genau verstehen
aber wir müssen ihn lesen wir müssen uns
auch in meinem russischen quellen
beschäftigen denn dieser simultane druck
zunahme die findet ganz kontrolliert
statt und sie ist kein zufall je länger
putin regiert desto mehr treibt ihn die
frage oben und auch die führungsschicht
die russische wie wird das einerseits
eines tages mit der machtsicherung
weitergehen deshalb wird immer mehr
repression nach innen gewandt wir sehen
uns aktuell der die duma besteht
ausschliesslich noch aus administrativen
administrierten parteien und
systemparteien memorial und andere
unnötige internationale kontakte werden
geschlossen die deutsche politische
stiftung und werden es immer schwieriger
haben tatsächlich dort zu arbeiten und
zu weiteren zuvor die letzten wahlen
dürften durch die osze nicht regulär
beobachtet werden eine geradezu
lächerliche kleine vision hätte nur
zugelassen werden sollen gott sei dank
hat die osze richtig darauf reagiert und
gesagt so eine farce machen wir nicht
usw und simultan dazu haben wir eine
zunahme des drucks ganz massiv auf die
nachbarstaaten exemplarisch am heutigen
thema und da ist es wichtig liebe
kolleginnen kollegen dass wir hier auf
die russischen quellen schauen der
chefhistoriker des kreml sergej
karaganow fordert einer der chefkritiker
pardon historiker des kreml spricht von
einem dritten kalten krieg den man auch
gewinnen können und er bringt beispiele
wie er mit hilfe chinas gewonnen werden
könnte andere sprechen nicht nur vom
kalten krieg und der präsident selbst
lassen sich mit genehmigung der
präsidentin ein zitat von wladimir putin
selbst bringen was in deutschland wenig
beachtet wurde vom 12 juli 2001 20 sagt
folgendes über das verhältnis zur
ukraine er sagt es war die sowjetische
nationalität politik die auf staatlicher
ebene die these von drei getrennten
slawischen völkern dem russischen
demokratischen mit dem belarussischen
fest schrieb statt der großen russischen
nation eines dreieinigen volks bestehend
aus großen klein russen und weißrussen
und er führt ein anderer stelle ford
gemeinsam waren wir schon immer ein
vielfaches stärker und werden es auch in
zukunft sein schließlich sind wir ein
volk so auf der homepage veröffentlicht
oder am bloody mir putin des russischen
präsidenten am 12 juli 2021 in
russischer sprache das ist die denkweise
der wir es zu tun haben das ist die
realität an der wir arbeiten müssen
deshalb dürfen wir kein wunschdenken
ansätzen ja wir müssen gespräche
anbieten es ist die stunde der partie
wir müssen aber auch stärke zeigen und
wir müssen deshalb auch aufbauend auf
der deutsch us erklärung vom juli
kollege schmidt hat sich angesprochen
auch ein glaubwürdiges und
abschreckendes szenario aufbauen wo
deutlich wird dass wir dies nicht
akzeptieren können und dass wir als
europa uns auch nicht
auseinanderdividieren lassen deshalb wie
die kolleginnen kollegen
es ist entscheider von entscheidender
bedeutung dass wir jetzt die instrumente
stärke die wir haben dass wir an die
ostsee erinnern in der tat eine deutsche
generalsekretären haben wir dort helga
schmidt ist man kann es nicht oft genug
sagen die eine fantastische arbeit macht
dort in ihrer in ihrer position und das
will sie stärken und die institutionen
der osze stärken ihre arbeit zu machen
beim beobachten der situation im don was
beim beobachten von wahlen bei der
menschenrechts beobachtung aber auch
gerade in ersten pfeiler in dem so oft
unterschätzten ersten pfeiler der osze
also gerade dort wo wir ja eigentlich
alle instrumente hätten
vertrauensbildend zu wirken aber
russland gesetzt die zusammenkommen in
diesem sinne liebe kolleginnen kollegen
stärken wir den multilateralismus und
arbeiten wir gemeinsam in dieser
wahlperiode für dieses ziel herzlichen
dank
michael georg link war das aus der
fdp-fraktion wie gesagt in der letzten
legislaturperiode europäischer
europapolitischer sprecher und er
verlangt diplomatie und stärke im umgang
mit russland und wolfgang hellmich ein
bisschen voreilig denn das pult muss
erst desinfiziert werden und die leser
natürlich getauscht aber jetzt ist der
spd politiker der ist mir die
aussenpolitiker angekommen
gelegenheit vielleicht auch heute ein
bisschen historische blick geben zu
können in einer so wichtigen dem pakt
über aktuelle konfliktlage es könnte
auch dem herrn deutschland helfen bei
der frage des lebenslangen lernens war
gestern vor 30 jahren wurde das abkommen
von biologisch unterzeichnet die
wenigsten wissen es noch für die ukraine
war das kein nikotin heute glauben
machen will und der kollege link hatte
die motivation gerade alle ganz richtig
beschrieben
ja es war keine geopolitische
katastrophe seien es war der beginn des
weges der ukraine in ein demokratisches
europa mit unserer ganzen unterstützung
in diesem vertrag einigten sich die drei
staatsoberhäupter von russland
weißrussland und der ukraine auf die
volle souveränität ihrer staaten auf die
territoriale integrität und die
sicherung berichtete bürgerinnen und
bürger auf der grundlage der un
menschenrechtskonvention und das prinzip
der nichteinmischung in innere
angelegenheiten und
heute
nichts davon wird von putin mehr
einlagen ich sage bewusst putin dank
auch den in was des kollegen link denn
es sind nicht die bürgerinnen und bürger
russlands gemein sondern es ist die
russische nomenklatura den moskau
herrscht und seit 2014 der
verabschiedung der geltenden russische
militärdoktrin sehen wir uns mehr und
mehr mit einer russischen föderation
konfrontiert wie jeden anspruch mit
ihren anrainerstaaten
panischer fliegen zu gehen aufgegeben
hat und deshalb verstehen sie auch diese
militäroptionen so gut weil ihr völker
gedanke den sie hier immer wieder
verbreiten ist ein bestandteil der
grundlage russische militärdoktrin in
russland ist zum patriotismus vielleicht
genannt bei uns ist das ein wirklicher
nationalismus der nicht grundlage
internationale politik sein darf in sein
kann weil es ist die ursache für kriege
und katastrophen die in ausreichendem
maß erlebt haben das wollen wir nicht
mehr es ist nicht polizeibekannt
aber es ist die grundlage an der zu
eines zunehmenden expansionismus
russlands mit mietern der hybriden
kriegführung von der offenen aktionen
der krim viele punkte sind beschrieben
um die faktische besetzung des ostens
der ukraine über die spende ukrainische
helfen gipfel diese politik in der
offenen druck mit truppen und schwerem
gerät an der ukrainischen grenze wie
soll es ein staat verstehen wenn
vielleicht eine übung im frühjahr diesen
jahres wie vielleicht als show of force
gesehen haben nein vielleicht
tatsächlich die übung schweres gerät und
combat rally truppen an die ukrainische
grenze zu bringen
über die frage vom politischen oft was
morgen im berliner tiergarten und den
fall skipper willig erinnern aber dieses
gehört alles in ein und dasselbe bild
eine strategie einer politik die auf
erpressung auf drohung und im
zweifelsfall das in kauf nehmen eines
krieg ist der auseinandersetzung mit mir
mit militärischen mittel aus es
diese bedrohung gut dienst an die
ukraine
keine ost erweiterung der nato zu
garantierenden die ukraine als
russisches einflussgebiet zu tolerieren
ist für uns kein grundlage von politik
und klar abzulehnen
nein auch die getragene selbst verweist
auch mit dem blick auf das wird auf den
vertrag auf ihre volle souveränität
integrität und dabei findet sie unsere
volle unterstützung nicht nur unsere
sondern die volle unterstützung des
gesamten demokratischen westens ist bei
ihren nach der konferenz im laufe der
letzten wochen nicht kenne ich keine die
aufnahme der ukraine in die nato
beschlossen worden nein
sind stark paketen in der ukraine
stationiert worden mit der russisches
territorium unmittelbar und direkt
bedroht wird nein das ist nicht so aber
es werden content gegen studer von putin
aufgebaut und dann im hintergrunde sagen
zu können dass legitimiert man völker
rechtswidriges anderen und verhalten ich
hoffe viele telefonate konferenz in
diesen tagen führen dazu dass die
ukrainischen menschen selber haben
wollen sie wollen in frieden leben sie
wollen die eskalation sie wollen keine
militärische auseinandersetzung 14.000
tote in der ukraine sind mal genug für
russland für putin in demokratische
strukturen in gespräche zurückzukehren
in die fragen der der der verhandlung
die türen sind alle offenen der rückkehr
in das form noch mal die format die
rückkehr des nato botschaft dass der
russlands nach brüssel all das im punkte
auf die wir setzen müssten er bot ihnen
lassen sie von mir hat die forderung ab
vom militärische machtdemonstration
wir brauchen gespräche deeskalation und
frieden und keine kriegstreiberei vielen
dank
wo es kein hellmich außenpolitiker in
der spd-fraktion im 1 außenpolitischen
aktuellen stunde des bundestags und
damit sind wir
letzten beim letzten redner angekommen
nicht nur in dieser debatte sondern auch
für diesen debatten tag insgesamt danach
ist der bundestag wollte erst mal zu
ende morgen gibt es ja noch mal eine
stunde zum thema cupid 19 bekämpfung und
insbesondere ausbau von impfungen oder
jetzt erstmal thomas ertl aus der
unionsfraktion csu landesgruppe für die
klaren worte weil in der tat die
situation sehr sehr besorgniserregend
ist rund 100000 russische soldaten
stehen und an der ukrainischen grenze
und das bereits zum zweiten mal in
diesem jahr diese russische provokation
die müssen wir klar verurteilen und die
ist eine ist ein teil dieser hybriden
vorgehensweise gegenüber dem westen und
unserer osteuropäischen partner und da
sehen wir von desinformation im internet
migrationsfrage in belarus bis hin zu
den raketen in kaliningrad nur 500
kilometer von hier viele andere
beispiele wurden auf meinem vorredner
aufgezeigt und soeben hat mir der
ukrainische botschafter wenig und mich
freut dass er die debatte hier auf der
tribüne verfolgt mit einem gespräch auch
die konkrete bedrohungslage und die
perzeption die wahrnehmung der
bevölkerung auch geschildert und wir
dürfen nicht vergessen im osten der
ukraine herrscht schon krieg täglich
werden dort soldaten verletzt 70
ukrainische soldaten sind in diesem jahr
gefallen also wir reden nicht über
theoretische szenarien sondern über
tägliche gewalt im osten europas und
deshalb muss für uns hier im hause klar
sein wir müssen eine weitere eskalation
der gewalt mit allen mitteln verhindern
wir zeigen uns solidarisch mit der
ukraine und stehen zu dem prinzip dass
jedes land seine außenpolitische
orientierung frei wählen kann rote
linien aus moskau dürfen wir nicht
akzeptieren
militärische aggression schon gar nicht
meine damen und herren
und deshalb ist jetzt unbedingt
notwendig dass auch die neue
bundesregierung diese moderierende rolle
fortführt die bundeskanzlerin merkel
auch in den vergangenen jahren
eingenommen hat aber trotzdem geht es
nur aus einer position der stärke heraus
und das bedeutet in erster linie vor
allem einigkeit und klarheit innerhalb
der bundesregierung und bisher meine
damen und herren deppen zumindest teile
der spd in einer traumwelt in der klare
sprache gegenüber russland fehlanzeige
war und natürlich brauner dialog und
gesprächsbereitschaft aber wir brauchen
auch härte und klare signale an moskaus
und da bin ich schon ziemlich bestürzt
wenn er mit sich am ersten tag der neuen
regierung der außenministerin in die
parade fährt und wer die russlandpolitik
ja aus den händen reißen will das ist
nicht die außenpolitik aus einem guss
die sie im koalitionsvertrag
aufgeschrieben haben ich meine das
schwächt unsere position außerdem glaube
ich brauchen wir eine klare
position zu nord typ 2 und
die frage wie geht s weiter jetzt in der
ukraine wird es normandie format
fortgeführt kann die regierung auch hier
zu dem gipfel der in berlin dann auch
stattfinden soll
einladen und was ist letztendlich dann
auch mit den
defensiv auch mit der
verteidigungsfähigkeit der ukraine die
auch robert habeck vor einigen monaten
demonstriert die
erwähnte für brauchen klare jetzt mehr
klarheit von dieser regierung meine
damen und herren wir werden von russland
auf vielen verschiedenen wegen
konfrontiert russland ist die zentrale
sicherheitspolitische herausforderung in
europa und der können wir nur aus einer
position der stärke heraus begegnen und
das muss ich hier noch einmal betonen
konkret bedeutet das
eine starke bundeswehr eine starke nato
starke transatlantische beziehungen und
das wäre schade dass dies zwei prozent
ziel durch verklausuliert im
koalitionsvertrag aufgeschrieben ist und
die fortführung zentraler europäischer
rüstungsvorhaben wie zb lefkas ist die
koalitionsvertrag gar nicht verankert
ohne solche projekte bleibt die vision
eine stärkung eines souveränen europas
ein wunschtraum und dass sie uns die
nato partner mit dem beitritt zum
atomwaffen verbots vertrag als
beobachter verwirren kommt dann auch
dazu und ist unserer ansicht nach auch
nicht hilfreich
meine damen und herren sicherheit in
europa gibt es nur mit russland und
deshalb ist wichtig dass die
bundesregierung jetzt eine klare
position findet die unsere interessen
die die interessen europas aufnimmt und
sich auch keinen träumereien hingibt
jede aggression russlands muss harte
konsequenzen mit sich bringen und diese
klare botschaft muss auch von der neuen
bundesregierung klar formuliert werden
er hat freuen darf
vielen dank herr kollege ernte und damit
sind wir am ende der debatte liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
nutzen sie den nachmittag und abend in
dem festen wissen dass sobald die
ausschüsse da sind es keine freien
donnerstag nachmittage und abende mir
geben wird von daher berufe ich nun die
nächste sitzung des deutschen
bundestages ein auf morgen freitag den
10 dezember 9 uhr die sitzung ist
geschlossen
das war nochmal so ist die bundestags-
vizepräsident den mit einem kleinen
hinweis an die
parlamentarierinnen und parlamentarier
und diese ausschüsse die sie da
angesprochen hat die werden am kommenden
mittwoch
installiert und dann wird hier
tatsächlich gearbeitet werden müssen
aber so richtig rund gehen wird es dann
wahrscheinlich auch erst im kommenden
jahr